however this same theory might have been
confirmed by recently published
behind-the-scenes photos as I already
brought you ten minutes long detailed
video about this theory today I'll try
to explain it to you as short as
possible
this theory of mine starts with Petyr
Baelish who did all he could have said
sense as a queen in the north
Littlefinger betrayed Ned Stark in order
to set up a fight between wolves and
lions then poison Joffrey on Joffrey's
own wedding to save Sansa and then that
same girl already tortured by the
Lannisters handed over to even more sick
oppressor Ramsay Bolton all in order to
turn the north against the Bolton's and
to give him an opportunity to lead the
Knights of the Vale that he is
commanding with by manipulating young
Lord Robin which he provided by killing
Romans father and mother all in order to
set Sansa as a queen in the north as we
saw by his face expression in the season
six finale Littlefinger didn't expect
that John who is not even the year of
House Stark would be proclaimed as the
King in the north by other northern
Lords and as we saw his face expression
that's also the moment in which he
started making a new plan his new plan
involves sand-sized his wife as a wife
with whom he would manipulate as he is
manipulating with Robin which would
provide him the northern army and would
lead him one step further to conquering
the Iron Throne his plan by this theory
is try to make a conflict between Jon
Snow and the north or to arrange John's
death but also to make sure that this
time he will get the northern army which
marrying Sansa would assure as i named
it the white wedding between sense and
Petyr Baelish would happen upon
Littlefinger's threat to censor that he
will pull the Vale troops back to the
Vale one less sense americium while Jon
Snow at this point will not be at
Winterfell John will be at Dragonstone
of course the first thought you have
right now probably is even if he would
want to Littlefinger could not command
to the Lords and the Knights of the Vale
but be careful about it and remember
what happened in the fourth episode of
the sixth season don't forget that the
Knights of the Vale were mobilised only
because of Peter only because of his
manipulation towards Lord Robin if some
of the lords from the Vale such as John
Royce
the Lord of Runestone wouldn't obey
Peters commands they would be sentenced
to death by the Lord of the Vale by Lord
Robin Arryn by the Lord who is
manipulated and does as Peter says
all the lords from the vaillar vessels
of how serene and have to do as Lord
Robin commands or otherwise that would
be executed before I go any further you
have to know that at this point
Sensa will not be alone in Winterfell
there will be her brother bran by her
side who will finally arrive home in the
first episodes of the seventh season
while her sister Arya will also arrive
at Winterfell a bit later with emotional
scenes between Arya brain and Sansa
there also come to the prominent
difference between two stark sisters
which will eventually result with Petyr
Baelish taking advantage of and
increasing those differences into a
conflict between two sisters Arya has
always had more rigid code while Sansa
has learned to be more pragmatic Arya
skilled killer and wants revenge
immediately while Sansa has more sorrow
manipulated way of doing things which
she learned from Littlefinger and Cersei
as well having developed very different
perspectives or insensible clash or the
matter of ruling upon noticing this
split between two sisters Petyr Baelish
will take his chance to take the
advantage of this certain situation by
increasing conflict between Arya and
Sansa which will not end Esbjerg Baelish
once according to leaked plot bran stark
will help his sisters to see through
little fingers game which will resolve
it senses sentencing Baelish to death
and Victoria are carrying out the same
sentence but let's get a little bit back
as I was saying Littlefinger will start
his new plan by marrying Sansa but at
the same time he will not be aware that
Sansa is manipulating him that sense
santeria found out the truth about his
betrayal over their father which they
will most probably find out from the
Hound at the Brotherhood without banners
he's heading north
there's also possibility that the stark
sisters will find it out from there
brother bran as it's easy to assume that
bran will most likely enter a vision and
go to the day of Ned's arrest in order
to find out who betrayed his father
which would provide his clear answer
however while there are a lot of
possibilities about how the Starks will
find out the truth there is no doubt
that he will finally find it out in the
seventh season that the moment in which
the wedding between Sense and Peter is
going to happen the moment which will
lead to their wedding night which is
orchestrated by two stark sisters by
sense and Arya as the Styrian continues
Littlefinger and sense after the wedding
feast will go to their room and while
they are
and well Baelish things that his cunning
skills and his genius mind again
resulted with the Starks being
manipulated in that very moment sensible
put a dagger down Littlefinger strode
the moment in which sensible entered the
room the moment in which we had to sense
us the moment in which aria is taking
off senses face while holding a dagger
on Peters throat whereupon arias killing
him with his own Valyrian steel dagger
was Sansa is watching as I already said
in a video by the named wife wedding in
season seven that I published more than
a few months ago as some kind of proof
that Aria is able to use face of someone
that is alive I'm relying on a scene
that took place in the final episode of
season 5 a scene in which a key hug our
warriors face was standing just beside
him in conclusion Aria would kill a man
that is among a few others guilty for
destruction of her family just as she
did in season 6 finale but now she will
kill a man that orchestrated her
father's death a man that set up a fight
between wolves and lions through the
Seven Kingdoms in the state of chaos
from which he personally benefited Aria
will most likely be the one to kill
Petyr Baelish now you're probably
wondering when and how this theory might
have been confirmed well a few days ago
Entertainment Weekly published a series
of behind the scenes photos featuring
Jon Snow Sansa bran and Arya hanging
around the set if you look closely on
Arya beside her very northern clothes
you can also notice her building an
unnamed Valyrian steel dagger that was
used by cat's paw during an
assassination attempt on bran Stark
however that dagger is currently in
possession of Littlefinger as he took it
from Ned after betraying him but it
seems that are able at some point of the
upcoming season now take it from Peter
as I don't see Baelish giving away such
a precious thing that Valyrian steel is
that precious that only a few houses
investors have while other Great Houses
would kill for to have it it's easy to
assume that Arya will either take it
from him upon killing him or will take
it from him while he's still alive only
to a bit later kill him with the same
illyrian steel dagger if you would like
to know more details about this theory
of mine about little fingers death that
seems more and more certain feel free to
check out a video by the name the white
wedding in season 7 in which I provided
you every single detail about it and as
always let me know your thoughts about
this theory in the comments
below do you think that this little
fingers fate would be a suitable death
for the man who is responsible for
almost every event in Westeros during
the war of the five kings for the man
that with his own machine ations
destroyed one house and almost destroyed
the other houses do you think that this
death would be suitable for him however
while it can be arguable that arya
building Littlefinger's Felina and still
dagger means that she will be the one to
kill him and while it can also be
arguable that this sweating tear will
come true one is certain Petyr Baelish
will not survive the upcoming season now
that I introduce you with this kind of
proof that goes in favor to my theory
let me now introduce you with the good
news about the seventh season each of
the seven episodes in seventh season
could be expected to be longer than the
average 55 minutes while the season
premiere will be the longest since the
62 minute series premiere will be 59
minutes long
however only the season premiere and
finale are confirmed to be a little
longer
it's said that finale this season will
be super-sized clocking in at well over
an hour also a few days ago showrunner
Daniel Weiss and cast members talked to
Entertainment Weekly and revealed their
major increase in screen time for season
7 Emilia Clarke said when I first read
this season I thought I gotta learn some
new lines and added we're actually
filming longer now I don't know how
that's happening another main character
Peter Dinklage agrees by saying I've
worked more days this season than I have
in quite some time
well it might be a little bit confusing
that the main characters will have more
screen time than in previous season even
though this season contains only 7
episodes showrunner rice explained it by
saying you kill a couple dozen
characters the people who are left by
default need to carry more dramatic
weight yes sir Daniel stills from season
7 had been released
providing us a closer look on Arya
Daenerys and Sansa in the first one we
get to see cent side Winterfell with an
amazing outfit with nice stark adornment
while the other two still Safari and
Danny are similar to promotional photos
released a month ago although it's been
rumored for a while that the eighth
final season will contain only sixth
episodes a few days ago HBO has
confirmed it to Entertainment Weekly and
as always let me know your opinion about
all of this in the comment section down
below I'm curious what your thoughts
about re-building Littlefinger's
Valyrian steel dagger about the white
wedding as well as about all those good
news about the seventh season the
giveaway winners will be announced in
the next video